welcome back to the last video in our
what-if tool mini series in the first
video james and i gave you an overview
of the what-if tool and in the second
video we did a deep dive of the data
point editor here we'll be focusing on
the performance and fairness tab using
the same housing data set from the last
two videos this model predicts whether a
house is worth more or less than
$160,000 let's get started the first
thing we see on the performance and
fairness tab are various performance
metrics for our model the confusion
matrix tells us the percentage of each
class our model classified correctly and
incorrectly if we add the numbers on the
top left diagonal it'll equal our
overall model accuracy in this case 97%
this shows us that 50 out of 51 data
points for my test set were correctly
classified as over $160,000 and 47 out
of 49 data points for my test network
correctly classified as less than
$160,000 the model had very few false
negatives and false positives so far we
haven't changed the threshold slider
Sara do you want to explain what we can
do with it sure the threshold indicates
your models decision point between
classes in this case any prediction
above 0.5 will be classified as more
than $160,000 changing the threshold is
one technique for optimizing your models
performance to change it in the wouldve
tool we can adjust the slider when we do
this you'll notice that our metrics
change in this case increasing the
threshold decreases overall accuracy but
also decreases our false positives if we
select a single threshold from the
optimization strategies the what if tool
will choose the threshold that yields
the highest overall accuracy on the
loaded data points so the lowest total
of false negatives and false positives
for this model it's still 0.5 this view
shows us how our model is behaving
across all data points but what if we
want to see how it's behaving across
different slices of our data that will
help us understand if there's areas
where it's treating subsets of data
points differently Sara do you want to
show us how to slice by different
features sure
let's try slicing by garage type
attached which indicates whether the
garage is attached to the house
notice that houses with an attached
garage have a higher likelihood that our
model will value them at more than
$160,000 now let's imagine that we
wanted our model to price houses with
attached and unattached garages in the
same way in this example we care most
about having the same percentage of
positive classifications across slices
while still achieving the highest
possible accuracy within that constraint
for this we should select demographic
parity as our optimization strategy from
the fairness section on the bottom left
notice that our threshold sliders and
accuracy metrics change when we set this
strategy
what do all these changes mean if we
don't want the garage placement to
influence our models price we need to
use different thresholds for houses
depending on whether the garage is
attached with these updated thresholds
the model will predict the house to be
worth more than hundred and sixty
thousand dollars when the predictive
score is 0.99 or higher
alternatively a house without an
attached garage should be classified as
over a hundred sixty thousand dollars if
the model predicts 0.52 are higher what
about other optimization strategies we
can use the equal-opportunity strategy
to achieve a similar percentage of
correct predictions across each slice
for the houses in our test data set that
are worth more than one hundred and
sixty thousand dollars and equal
accuracy will strive for similar
accuracy across both slices finally one
more performance and fairness feature we
should look at is changing the cost
ratio so far all of our optimization
strategies have tried to pick the best
thresholds given that we care equally
about false positives and false
negatives but this may not be the case
for many models for a model used in
cancer screening for example you might
want the model to avoid false negatives
meaning misdiagnosis at the cost of
having more false positives which could
then be screened out at the next level
of testing to update thresholds based on
how you want your model to handle false
positives and negatives you can change
the cost ratio for example setting the
cost ratio to 4 means that we want to
consider false negatives four times as
costly as false positives then we can
find the optimal threshold given this
new cost ratio we've covered a lot in
this video to recap we looked at a few
metrics for evaluating the performance
of a model
including the confusion matrix and true
and false positive rates then we looked
at modifying the prediction threshold
and analyzed how our model behaved
across different slices of our data keep
in mind that while this is a data set of
houses we'd want to do a similar
analysis for other types of data
especially human centered data it's also
important to note that we've shown just
one strategy for improving the fairness
of an ml model there are many other
methods available for this such as
augmenting training data and designing
fair cost functions for use out training
time for more resources and everything
we showed check out the links in the
video description thanks for watching
[Music]